they're here aren't they mr. Mulder  they've been here for a long long time  why don't give you guys a ride home  octavia gonna check myself out you'd  like a day pass maybe check out Las  Vegas you could do some serious damage  someplace like that I'm not going to Las  Vegas I'm not going anywhere not without  mrs. Caffey  huh Omaima James what do we do  what's no no no I wrote all the networks  Fox was the only one who any interest in  it I don't know why  federal marshals business isn't in here  it's out there trying to catch those two  convicts no ma'am  once I heard y'all was interested I  figured we'd best leave it to the  experts  in E Street basketball now the bull  sucks it seemed very peaceful  you